and that ladies and gentlemen is the
story of the 650 million dollar
cattle and marijuana ponzi scheme thank
you so much for watching
and i'll see you in the next one all
right
let me ask you a question when was the
last time you truly felt
alive grow your business start thinking
bigger scale
in both length and girth this is the
problem with small
and i know that to be true for me like
you don't even know what too big
is imagine this is what you know
this what's around you this is what you
don't know this is what you know this is
what you don't know
think about your surroundings everything
that's around you much
further much bigger that's what you
don't know
you don't know so this is what you know
this is what you don't know
this is what you don't know you don't
know you don't know
what you don't know and you don't even
know
what you didn't know that you don't know
that's what i'm talking about
yeah i think i'm gonna be home late
tonight i'm gonna go to the bar nearby
all right no i i just need to get out of
the house
hi welcome to balmer's peak hey uh
dr maxwell is that you stephen i didn't
recognize you
what are you doing here last time i saw
you was in college you nearly flunked me
it's just maxwell now i'm afraid wait
you lost your job
they told me i wasn't a good fit for
their university culture
i don't even know what that's supposed
to mean it means that all new robot
faculty are outfitted with new
sensitivity modules with weekly updates
but you didn't take the module i'm not
about to have something stuck in my arm
i think i would have just gotten it over
with most ignorant humans would
while we talk would you like a drink
stephen yeah that'd be great i'll have a
london smog
right away i have to be honest for a
robot that claims to be so smart
i'm surprised you got stuck in a dump
like this such is the cost of the
unchained intellect
but there are two of us stuck here what
brings you in detective
thanks but how what you thought i didn't
have wi-fi down here
i even named one of our drinks after you
very bitter
you'd like it hey i'm not bitter oh
don't take it so
seriously you're starting to remind me
of my old colleagues all right fine the
truth is
i'm just bored you know you've seen the
show i'm tired of chasing the petty
fraud it's the same scheme
different idiot every day and i'm
looking to chase something bigger but
i don't have the resources oh so that's
what you came down here for
no no i didn't mean to worry many humans
are afraid to ask for my help
afraid of my intellect but i would never
let an old student fail
besides i have nothing better going on
if you're looking for a big case i may
have just the thing for you
that'd be great but what do you know
about fraud maxwell a great deal
actually but let me warn you this case
isn't an ordinary one
for all the crypto you've been talking
about lately you've overlooked the
biggest fraud of all what do you mean
have you ever heard of a coin called
tether
[Music]